Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass – was ist los in la Liga, der Premier League, der Serie A und der Liga A? Diese Frage wollen wir heute beantworten in der Ligatur in diesem Rasenfunk Kurzpass Nummer 245. Hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Das hier ist die Ligatur. Schön, dass ihr eingeschaltet habt. Wir wollen auf den europäischen Männerfußball blicken. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich bin der Etge Netzer. Auf Twitter und auf mastodon.social freue ich mich sehr, dass ihr eingeschaltet habt und ich freue mich sehr auf unsere Runde, die heute besteht aus. Zum einen Uli Hebel. Hallo Uli. Dann ist noch Nils Kern hier. Hallo Nils. Schöne Grüße. Marius Soyke ist hier. Hallo, Marius.
Ja, finde ich auch super. Denn der Blick auf den Abstiegskampf generell ist ja sehr interessant. Du hast ja gerade den Trainerwechsel in Leeds schon angesprochen. Das haben vielleicht auch die Hörerinnen und Hörer mitbekommen. Die haben eben 22 Punkte. West Ham zur Erinnerung nochmal 23. Everton 21, Bournemouth 21. Und wenn wir nach oben gucken, sind Wolverhampton die Wanderers mit 24. Und Leicester mit 24. Jetzt auch nicht so weit weg. Und man könnte sogar noch weiter hochgehen. Also es ist sehr eng da hinten drin. Und es stehen eben so manche Namen mit dabei, mit denen jetzt nicht zu rechnen war. West Ham, sicherlich auch Everton. Bei allem, was da schiefgelaufen ist, dass man nur 21 Punkte hat, ist natürlich trotzdem mehr als nur ärgerlich. Was glaubst du, wer hat da unten gerade die besten Karten? Und um wen musste man sich Sorgen machen?
Also bei Leicester glaube ich, ist die Qualität im Kader zu gut. Die habe ich nicht mehr drin. Also die beiden mit 24 Punkten, die würde ich allein schon deshalb rausnehmen auch. Bei den Wolves ist es das Gleiche. Die sind qualitativ zu hochwertig. Und dann muss ich es eigentlich von hinten her rechnen. Southampton, die machen mir richtig Angst, so wie die spielen. Da gab es jetzt unter dem neuen Trainer, der jetzt inzwischen fix ist, also Ruben Sayes, hat jetzt zumindest mal das Magnetat bekommen bis zum Saisonende. Das sah einspiel-lang okay aus, bestenfalls okay. Das war auch nicht gut. Aber sie haben zumindest nichts zugelassen und haben dann vorne irgendwas reingemurmelt. Das war okay, aber um die habe ich richtig Angst. Das glaube ich grundsätzlich, auch wenn die auch einen neuen Besitzer haben, nochmal ordentlich investiert im Winter. Da sind ein, zwei interessante Spieler dabei, aber aus meiner Sicht keine totalen Soforthilfen. Auch um die habe ich Angst. Das sind die zwei, die ich fast sicher als Abstiegskandidaten habe. Dann wird es die große Frage. Everton hat jetzt mit John Deitsch einen neuen Trainer, der glaube ich sehr, sehr gut dahin passt, soweit irgendwann mal irgendwas zusammengepasst hat bei Everton. Da ist gleich noch dahinter. Bei Leeds bin ich mir auch nicht so ganz sicher, auch wenn ich die Trainer-Verpflichtung mit Javi Gracia jetzt mag. Einer, der eher mal erst mal das Zentrum zusperrt und nicht hau-ruck spielt wie Jesse Marsch. Ich mag das grundsätzlich, aber ich fürchte, einen von den beiden wird es erwischen, weil – und da sind wir dann wieder bei West Ham – West Ham am Ende immer noch zu leicht, nicht sehr viel, aber leicht zu gut ist. A, was die individuelle Qualität betrifft, und B, was zumindest den spielerischen – also spielerisch darf man ihn ja nennen – aber was den Plan betrifft, den David Moyes hat, den die Mannschaft kennt zuallermeist und in der Regel auch umsetzt. Das Problem ist gar nicht so sehr, dass sie nicht tun, was er will, sondern es ist deutlich zurückgegangen in Sachen Effizienz. Da waren sie in den letzten Jahren so krass drüber, dass sie in dieser Saison merken, wenn sie mal leicht drunter sind. Sie sind gar nicht deutlich unter den Expected Goals, aber leicht drunter, weil Chancenverwertung nicht so gut sind und weil vor allen Dingen die Flanken, die essenziell sind für das Spiel der Hammers, nicht genau kommen, nicht verwertet werden können. In der Folge gibt es auch keine zweiten Bälle. Und so einfach ist es dann manchmal schon zu erklären, warum es nicht läuft. Weil die Werte läuferisch etc. sind alle ziemlich gleich. Auch die Pressingwerte sind alles ziemlich gleich in den Vorsaisons, aber da krankt es.
Ja, und vielleicht auch so ein bisschen generell an der Ausrichtung, weil wenn du sagst, die Expected Goals, die sind ungefähr Pari Pari. Also das, was man statistisch gesehen hätte machen sollen, hat man auch gemacht. Dann würde ich sagen, naja, aber 23 Tore aus 24 Spielen sind ja dann auch wirklich nicht viel.
Nee, also sie sind schon in den Expected Goals deutlich drunter, wenn man es jetzt in dieser Saison vergleicht. Ich habe jetzt gemeint in den Vorsaisons.
Okay, falsch verstanden.
Vielleicht habe ich es auch einfach nur komisch ausgedrückt in einer allgemeinen sehr langen Antwort, wie mir aufgefallen ist. Auf eine gar nicht so lange Frage und gar nicht so komplexe Frage. Aber so ist es manchmal. Nein, es ist tatsächlich so. Die Abschlussqualitäten sind zu schwach. Es gibt eigentlich nur einen Spieler, der im 1 gegen 1 was richtig machen kann. Also klar, es gibt Jared Bohn, der viel Tempo hat, aber nicht so richtig im 1 gegen 1 Frontal eine Lösung findet. Der Einzige, der da generell mal Kreatives mitbringt, ist Seid Ben Rama. Und er spielt aber zu selten in der Startformation. Witzigerweise gibt es die Korrelation sehr wohl. Wenn er spielt, sind sie sehr viel erfolgreicher. Aber das heißt ja noch lange nicht, dass er ihn immer bringt, der David Beuys.
Ich hatte mal vor, das ist jetzt schon ein paar Jahre her, da war glaube ich Raphael Honigstein hier zu Gast. Und der hat damals zu mir gesagt, weil da habe ich ihn auch nach dem Abstiegskampf gefragt, dann hat er gesagt, boah, also das interessiert halt hier die Leute gar nicht so sehr, außer halt die Fans der beteiligten Vereine. Ist das denn immer noch so, wenn jetzt auch so große Namen, ohne jetzt anderen zu nahe treten zu wollen, aber eben so größere Namen mit unten drin hängen?
Das würde ich nicht sagen. Also klar hat jetzt nicht die Aufmerksamkeit von Manchester United oder wenn bei Liverpool irgendwas nicht läuft. Das ist klar. Aber ich finde schon, dass alleine durch die Teilnahme, sei ich jetzt mal unfreiwillig, am Abstiegskampf von Leeds und Everton und deren chaotischen Dinge, die da so gelaufen sind, dass da schon ein großes Augenmerk drauf liegt. Das finde ich schon. Vielleicht hat Marius vorher auch mal kurz gesagt, das mag dann auch immer eine Frage des Konsums sein. Ich hänge jetzt nicht auf den Seiten ab, die jetzt so klassisch der Mainstream sind, sondern versuche dann schon immer etwas tiefer zu gehen. Aber ich finde, dass es da sehr wohl berichtet wird. Und es gibt auch von denen, die es gucken, also sowohl in unserem Inland jetzt als auch in England und was ich so mitkriege umliegend, durchaus Teilnahme am Abstiegskampf. Das würde ich so nicht sehen. Aber kann auch sein, dass das tatsächlich eine Entwicklung ist. Da muss ich mal drüber nachdenken, ob das früher nur nicht so war und das jetzt so ist. Oder ob ich einfach schon viel zu tief in dieser Bubble bin. Das kann natürlich auch sein.
Es hilft wahrscheinlich dann nicht, dass man da einen wöchentlichen Podcast darüber macht. Aber das haben ja hier drei von euch vieren miteinander gemeinsam. Dann lasst uns noch ein letztes Mal nach Frankreich blicken. Michi, da hast du uns noch PSG als Thema mitgebracht. Wir haben PSG gegen den FC Bayern gesehen. Da hat man 0-2-1 verloren. Ich glaube, dieses Spiel, wer sich dafür interessiert, der hat das mitverfolgt und auch nachgelesen, wie das ungefähr gelaufen ist. Danach gab es ein aufsehenerregendes 4-3 gegen Lidl. Da lag man lange Zeit zurück, hat dann spät ausgeglichen und noch später den Siegtreffer erzielt. Und dann ein sehr viel erwartetes Aufeinandertreffen mit Marseille, denn Marseille war der Verfolger, von dem man dachte, die könnten vielleicht an den Fersen von PSG hängenbleiben. Wenn ich jetzt dieses 3 zu 0 sehe, ist es dann so, dass jetzt wieder alles super ist bei PSG und alles hat sich beruhigt und alle gehen geregelt ihrer Arbeit nach oder ist es wie immer bei PSG?
Sehr schöne rhetorische Frage. Auf keinen Fall. Ruhig ist es da sowieso nie. Natürlich hat der Sieg die Wogen geglättet, auch von der Intensität her haben die Marseille wirklich niedergerungen. Gerade am Anfang war das ein sehr starkes Spiel. Und da hat PSG Qualitäten gezeigt, die sie lang verborgen gehalten haben. Hatten dann noch diesen, ich nenne es jetzt mal Schicksalsschlag, mit Kim Bap-P, der sich verletzt hat, der aus der Jugend ist, der ein Urgestein ist, der von jedem geachtet wird und deshalb auch einer der Führungsspieler ist und eben vorher schon lange verletzt war und dann nochmal verletzt vom Platzmuster, der jetzt länger ausfällt. Und das hat schon ein bisschen was bewirkt, hat schon so einen Push gegeben dem gesamten Team. Das ist schon positiv. Allerdings bleibt dieser Verein eine Ansammlung von Spielern, die, wenn sie wollen, Weltklasse sind und wenn sie aber eben nicht wollen oder wenn ein, zwei, drei nicht wollen, die dann auch mal verlieren können gegen Mannschaften aus der unteren Tabellenhälfte. Und ich glaube, wenn die jetzt gegen Bayern weiterkommen, dann wird es auch in der Liga wieder besser, weil es kann natürlich auch noch mal Schwung geben. Aber wenn die ausschalten, dann wird es auch noch mal um den Trainer gehen. Dann wird es um die Offensivreihe gehen. Dann wird es vor allem um die Ausrichtung gehen. Es drängt sich jetzt gerade die Frage auf, wie spielt man denn gegen Bayern? Spielt man mit einer Dreierkette hinten und zwei Offensiven außen, obwohl Kimpempe ausfällt und dann natürlich einen Innenverteidiger ran muss, den man mit Milan Skriniar gern gehabt hätte, schon seit einem Jahr, der aber nicht gekommen ist. Und man dann eben einen Talent einsetzen muss. Oder man opfert einen aus der offensiven Dreierreihe, was eigentlich unmöglich ist, weil das hat schon Maurizio Pochettino versucht und da ging es schief. Bei Neymar und bei Messi wird sich das nicht mehr getraut. Und bei Mbappé schon gleich.
Aber wird denn Neymar spielen können? Weil gegen Marseille zum Beispiel haben sie ja quasi mit so einem 3-5-2 gespielt, mit Mbappé und Messi vorne drin. Und wenn ich mir einfach nur – ich habe das Spiel nicht gesehen, aber ich sehe hier 1 zu 0 Mbappé nach Vorlage Messi, 2 zu 0 Messi nach Vorlage Mbappé, 3 zu 0 Mbappé nach Vorlage Messi und Messi hat auch noch einen Aluminium-Treffer mit dabei gehabt. Also es scheint jetzt nicht so schlecht funktioniert zu haben.
Genau, richtig. Bei dem Spiel auf keinen Fall. Aber es gab eben auch die Spiele davor. Seit der Winterpause haben die keine gute Bilanz gehabt. Das war meiner Ansicht nach das erste Spiel, wo sie wirklich vollumfänglich überzeugt haben. Natürlich sind sie die besten Freunde, wenn sie dann gut sind, wenn sie dann natürlich auch motiviert sind gegen so ein Team. Und im Pokal gab es eben die Niederlage dann. Also im Pokal sind sie gegen OM rausgeflogen. Und da hatte sich dann ganz plötzlich keiner mehr liebt. Das ist halt ein sehr schwankendes Konstrukt dabei, PSG. Und das mündet dann eben in einer Bilanz, die dann so eine Tabellenkonstellation wie vor ein paar Wochen noch herstellt, wo PSG keine 8 Punkte – ich glaube aktuell haben sie 8 Punkte Vorsprung. Also da hatten sie zeitweise auch mal nur 2 Vorsprung. Und dann war Monaco auf den Fersen. Dann war teilweise Lance auf den Fersen. Lance hat es ja auch geschlagen. Lance, die keiner auf den Zettel hatte oder wenige vor der Saison. Und ja, da haben viele gehofft, dass so etwas wie mit Lille vor ein paar Jahren passiert, dass irgendjemand ihnen den Drang abläuft. Und Marseille war da schon die Mannschaft, die das am ehesten hätte tun können, aber jetzt mit 8 Punkten Vorsprung. Naja, viel wird da wahrscheinlich nicht mehr passieren.
Da gibt es ja wirklich erstaunliche Parallelen zu Bayern. Aber das will ich jetzt nicht überstrapazieren, vor allem weil wir über Bayern nur nicht wissen, ob die es wieder schaffen, sich einen Vorsprung herauszuspielen. Den haben sie nämlich jetzt gerade nicht. Was ist denn so dein Gefühl mit Blick auf dieses Rückspiel? Was erwartest du?
Boah, das ist sehr schwer zu sagen. Also, lass PSG ein Tor machen und alles läuft gut. Oder lass die nächste Remodelle passieren und dann schlägt Bayern wieder zurück. Weil dieses Gebilde bei PSG durch eine Erschütterung eben zum Einsturz gebracht werden kann, was man im Herbst noch nicht gedacht hatte, weil sie da sehr stark performt haben. Ein Neymar schien in der Spur zu sein, der zum Medientermin, wie es vorher noch nicht gemacht hatte, durchweg pünktlich kam. Ein Messi, der sich integriert hat, und ein Mbappé, der sich mit allen verstanden hat, weil er jetzt einen unfassbar hochdotierten Vertrag in der Tasche hatte. Das ging eben verloren. Deswegen glaube ich immer noch nicht, dass dieser Kader ausgewogen genug ist, um Almstand zu halten. Ich tippe darauf, dass PSG weiterkommt. Aber das steht auf ganz wackeligen Füßen. Das ist jetzt ein Tipp. Aber weil ich weiß, wie leicht es ist, diese Mannschaft aus dem Konzept zu bringen. Ganz schwer zu sagen. Es ist fast 50-50. Aber ich würde jetzt mal sagen 55. Zu 45 für PSG, trotz der Hinspielerlage.
Am nächsten Mittwoch, den 8. März, wird das Rückspiel steigen. Wenn ich mir etwas wünschen könnte, dann wäre es ein Shootout zwischen Eric-Maxime Choupo-Moting und Juan Bernat. Genau, Uli Hoeneß wird dann schon auch teilnehmen. Da wird dann schon der Saun den richtigen Querschnitt machen. Der Saun produziert ja auch die Bilder. Wenn ich das richtig gemerkt habe, ist es ja in der Champions League so, dass die Rechteinhaber die Bilder produzieren. Aber bevor ich mich da jetzt weiter aufs Glatteis bewege, eine abschließende Frage an euch alle vier. Und dann seid ihr entlassen. Du darfst dann gleich loslegen, Michi. Welches Spiel jetzt in der Liga – ich will jetzt nicht PSG gegen Bayern hören – am Wochenende ist in deiner Meinung nach besonders bemerkenswert. Und sollte man sich vielleicht nachverfolgen?
In meiner Liga? Also in Frankreich?
Also in Frankreich, ja.
Ganz klar, Startrennen gegen Olympique Marseille. Die spielen am Sonntagabend. Und da geht es dann – also im Rennen ist aktuell, ich meine, fünf oder sechs Punkte hinter Marseille als Fünfter. Marseille ist Zweiter. Also da können die heranrücken. Und auch an Laus und Monaco, die noch davor stehen. Und spielerisch wird es total interessant.
Das kann man sich angucken in der Liga. Marius, in der Serie A, welches Match to watch gibt es da?
Ich würde zwei auf jeden Fall empfehlen. Und das ist natürlich nominell. Schon allein damit begründet am Freitagabend empfängt Napoli Lazio. Und Napoli kann man sich im Moment einfach immer geben. Uli hatte ja vorhin schon einmal Ozyman angesprochen. Und das United braucht einen Stürmer, der aus jeder Position Traumtore oder Tore erzielen kann. Ozyman kann das und macht auch Traumtore aus den spitzesten Winkeln. Und am Sonntagabend empfängt die Roma Juve. Das wird sicherlich nicht das attraktivste Fußballspiel, aber da steckt natürlich sehr viel drin und sehr viel Emotion. Und ich glaube, das kann man sich dann auch ganz gut geben.
Uli, was wartet auf uns in der Premier League?
Ich kann natürlich nur eins nennen, Arsenal gegen Bournemouth, weil der Kommentator sensationell ist. Im Ernst, ich glaube, Liverpool United ist schon heiß. Und ich freue mich persönlich auch sehr auf Montagabend, Brentford gegen Fulham.
Das ist einmal der Obvious-Tipp und einmal dann noch der Feinschmecker, der Gourmet-Tipp. Sehr schön. Und dann, ja gut, Nils, muss ich dich überhaupt fragen, ob wir uns was angucken sollen?
Genug gemeckert, Leckeres gibt es trotzdem in der Liga. Ob das Atletico gegen Sevilla ist, Betis gegen Real Madrid, aber vor allem Sonntag 16.15 Uhr, Barca gegen FC Valencia. Ich meine, Barca kriegt jetzt am Donnerstagabend die dritte Niederlage in Folge. Mal schauen. Und der FC Valencia, neuer Trainer Ruben Barracher, hat das erste Spiel verloren, dann zu Hause gewonnen. Also dort ist ein bisschen die Hoffnung zurück. Sie sind ja noch auf Abstiegsplatz. Und deswegen wird das, glaube ich, ein besonderes, auch kampfvolles Duell, Barca gegen Valencia am Sonntagnachmittag.
Aber das klingt wirklich sehr, sehr gut. Ihr vier, ich danke euch sehr. Uli Hebel für die Premier League, Nils Kern für La Liga, Marius Soyke zur Serie A und Michael Postl mit einem fantastischen Debüt zur Ligue 1. Ich werde alle eure Social-Media-Handels verlinken in den Show notes. Danke euch vier, dass ihr mal Zeit für die Ligatur hattet. Ihr dürft jetzt alle gemeinsam sagen, gerne. Gott, jetzt fühle ich mich wie so ein Lehrer, der morgens begrüßt wird. Naja, egal. Ich danke auch euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, für eure Aufmerksamkeit, wenn ihr es nicht mitbekommen habt. Letzten Donnerstag ist ein Kurzpass zur 2. Männer-Bundesliga erschienen. Und es wird jetzt dann die Rasenfunk-Schlusskonferenz Nummer 400 geben. Die nehme ich am Sonntagabend auf. Und am Montagabend nehme ich dann den nächsten Kurzpass zur Frauen-Bundesliga auf. Es wird durchgeballert im Rasenfunk, wie ihr es nicht anders verdient habt. Danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Bitte unterstützt uns. Rasenfunk.de slash supporters club ist die Adresse der Wahl. Und dann hören wir uns bald hier wieder. Bleibt gesund.